hey tv
[Applause]
[Music]
fellas it's so good to see you guys
again because the last time we talked
was the pop-up for all about love your
last full album in la and then the whole
world change and here you are with your
second english language album the
dreaming talk to me about the
inspiration for this latest record so
since uh the album name is the dreaming
we were like wanted to meet our fans as
soon as possible so you know meeting
fans to us it's kind of like a dreaming
so we named it like the dreaming yeah
two years right yeah after the last time
you saw us
you missed them huh your fans so much
[Music]
they got
so this week you're also sharing the
concert film for the dream right and i
know that you guys said it is a gift to
the fans so what are you gifting them
what are they about to see in this movie
so how to love our fans how to uh how to
make our music
yeah
how to make performance yeah all the
process um
because back in the day we just shown
all the results like i mean like
the
outfit when we are on the stage how we
look on the stage but we just wanted to
show like the process how we make all
the things and behind the scenes like
very honest
things about when we like prepare
something right very like some kind of
like that so how honest do you get are
there tears are you guys really open and
emotional and vulnerable yeah yeah we
were so honest when we were filming the
movie and
actually we swear a lot but i think it
cut it like they hit it
okay okay so tears but no swearing
that's right was it fun to watch it back
yeah yeah
it like it really gave us some nostalgia
so like we were missing the back
i mean
the
there was lots of like shots since 2015
and when we were so baby
so it's the whole
the whole journey
wow obviously you guys have accomplished
so much in your career so far but what
would you say has been the biggest dream
come true so far so far yeah so far so
far
maybe concert
with our fans because colby is yeah
situations yeah
yeah i think that is gold yeah the last
word tour maybe okay
which was that big mm-hmm so so what's
the next big dream then
actually we have a tour out of january
yeah yeah please do not cancel
can you tell yes
please
can you tell these guys want to go on
the road they want to perform live for
you guys don't cancel
don't
don't please
please i mean it's
literally a dream to us because
i think it took almost two years two
years now our friends again long time
yeah yeah i think crying on stage
maybe you think so maybe yeah what's the
vision for the show we are still
planning you start you are and we have
lots of like meeting with our company so
we cannot tell in detail i really want
to tell everything about that but
it's not ready yet yeah okay it's not
ready this is business this is why
business
this is i won't take it personal then
it's business i get it i get it okay
well you know what i know you guys are
physically preparing though because i
see you guys posting in the gym ever
since you got to the u.s you guys are
all working now yeah yeah did you see
that i saw it the fans saw it
yeah how much time are you guys in the
gym well when we would just wake up we
just go to the gym okay currently and
yeah workouts for five protein yeah yeah
except
you're not working out
no i'm so tired
you got to get it rest right you need
rest you're just drinking water
so i want to know
before you guys go on stage do you have
like a pre-show ritual oh well um
in my case i'm rolling
yeah because you don't have to go to the
restroom in the middle of a show yeah
yeah
how about you what do you do before a
show uh
uh eating something yup okay so he
sleeps and he eats
drinking water he drink water yeah
very important eating
and sleeping
yeah i love it i respect it i really do
i do
uh okay so obviously you guys look so
sharp today your fans whether you're at
the airport or on stage they love your
fashion so how would you each describe
your personal
style with you
p-o-o-l
pool
p-o-r p-o-u-r-p-e-o-r
no no no you're r-i-c-h rich
i like some kind of simple style like
very simple but casual but look kind of
fancy difficult
right airport uh
junior in university what's that yeah
in airport you're kind of like a
freshman yeah
oh like college
oh university style okay okay i like
street style like hip-hop yeah yeah like
spring
yeah
okay yeah
from college to the streets okay
my case black and white and
gorgeous it's amazing it's amazing okay
so how would you guys say you know your
music informs your style i mean like
when we are like performing kind of like
a strong
song we
wear some lots of
accessories and like
steel
necklace
some kind of that yeah when we are in
some kind of like like calm mood we just
wear some
suit but nothing inside
yeah yeah i don't know what you should
always
know why but i'm gonna give you guys a
chance to talk to your fans directly
right now to camera what message do you
have for the fans be happy stay happy we
love you guys
yeah see you at the world tour and i
hope you enjoyed the movie
say happy birthday
please
be careful be careful
[Music]
[Music]
you